give each country a blank canvas with no
rules and you can expect the results to
be unique but strangely national flags
are pretty similar
44 have three horizontal stripes ten
have one five pointed star on the left
side and only eleven flags aren't red or
blue and sure maybe these are just
popular colors but then where is the
much-loved purple the necessary coloring
wasn't always easy to come by but it's
2016 and this is still the most purple
flag you've got to be kidding me
of course there are a few oddball flags
but they're mostly different for the
same reason weird shapes so let's settle
this
why are flags so similar the idea of a
flag is to reflect its country take the
national history identity or even
appearance transfer it to a rectangle
and voila a flag but this means that
similar countries conveying similar
things can have similar flags the Arab
revolt was a pretty big deal its flag
became the inspiration for much of the
Middle East Egypt Iraq Kuwait Sudan
Syria the UAE Palestine Yemen Somaliland
and Libya chair a history and thus
similar Flags Cyprus a master of
copy-paste has no overlap to worry about
with no restraints flags could easily
all be unique but countries often follow
rules of design and with everyone the
pool of possible flags drinks simplicity
is a common recommendation which makes
for a pretty flag but not always a
distinct one Monaco Indonesia and Poland
accidentally sacrificed originality for
elegance other countries take
inspiration from their neighbors the
story of the Nordic cross goes something
like this
Denmark found this design and announced
Hey look we have a new flag to which
Sweden replied how odd
we also have a new flag Finland Norway
and Iceland not wanting to feel left out
all nodded along and Greenland pretended
not to hear but perhaps all this isn't
so bad
if the rectangles which represent us are
so similar
maybe we're all more alike than it seems
or perhaps we're just not very creative
for their Flags can someone create a
purple flag just one please just need
one